so Patrick what are the first things
that you do when you arrive on set as a
cameraman or a DP can you take us
through how you're scouting a location
how you're envisioning setting up shots
hmm yeah i mean when i when i start a
film i I don't do a lot of shooting at
first I spend quite a bit of time with
you know with our subjects and with the
story and I leave the camera in the bag
so I may spend several days or wander
maybe a week just getting to know our
subjects and and allowing them to get
chance to know us so that's that's sort
of the first thing we do and I've been
shooting for 25 years now so you know
and I shoot most of our own work
although on if you build it we had a
really talented DP named George de sorte
who also did a lot of shooting with us
but you know I look for the light
honestly not to sound too artsy fartsy
but I I don't like to use lights when
we're shooting because I think lighting
on the set of a documentary is pretty
unnatural so you know we look for how to
what's where is there enough light to
shoot the story we don't shoot the story
very often at night if we could avoid it
and then we just tried them once we kind
of have our bearings and understand the
locations and understand the stories
that we start shooting
you